Hey guys!
Guess what...
I have bronchitis
And that is absolutely terrible timing considering everything that we've been trying to do this past week.
And not that we haven't been successful,
but if you've noticed, this past few days we've been trying to do The 12 Days of Christmas,
all starting with the actual video "12 Days of Christmas."
And it's something that we've wanted to do for a while now
it's something that we've been planning.... and it's something we've been moderately successful at.
All things considered even though I have been extremely ill the past few days
I've had a fever, body aches, chills, just general tiredness and my voice flipping in and out
my voice actually came back for a little bit and I was able to record a little bit but I went at it too hard
and yesterday I couldn't speak in more than a hushed whisper, I wouldn't have even been able to do this vlog
if I hadn't have spent to whole day quiet.
And in fact, I kinda got everybody else sick
Uh, Tyler, Ethan, Kathryn and Amy, I got them all sick
because of whatever the hell I brought back from the UK.
and if you don't know what bronchitis is
it an infection of the bronchial tubes in the lungs, it means you're sick and feel terrible
and you gennerally cough up a buch of unpleasent GUNK.
All that disgustingness aside I am really happy with what we've been doing.
we've been like nose to the grind stone working our asses off
despite everything! I'm so proud of everybody else
and I'm proud of myself that I've been
able to keep going cause it's been this drive to commit to this thing
uh  that I've wanted to do, the 12 days of Christmas
and we've been doing it very successfully
albeit, I mentioned, with a few tweaks here and there
like we, we wanted to do more challenge based stuff
we wanted to do more things like the ginger bread house building challenge
and we had  like building a snow-man challenge... present wrapping challenge
christmas tree decorating challenge
all with twists that make them very interesting
UM
and we weren't  able to do that because my voice just completely shut down on me it was so weird
because usually when I get sick, I get sick for one or two days maybe three
ah  my voice goes out cause usually it like a throat infection
and then it comes back and it ..it... i was sick my throat went out and then it came back
and in that span I recorded as much as I could
but I went at it so hard my voice just kinda exploded on me
and like I said I absolutely couldn't talk yesterday.
and it's still a little rough today because my high range
*Mark screams hoarsely*
is not quite there
and thats really sad because i wanna tell you guys what we had planned
to do. all this was going to be leading up
to..... on Christmas day we were actually going to make a full cover song
of "Silent Night", and I was gonna sing it
and I'm really sad that, that's not able to happen
because I literally don't have a voice
it was so frustrating to have this thing come... NOW
when we were also preparing to all go back to our families we're leaving in 2 days
all to go back to our families to celebrate christmas and we're trying to get ahead on recording.
and we're trying to get ahead on videos and we've been moderately successful in that
but nowhere near as we would've been
if I had not brought back sickness from the UK.
so I wanna say thank you everybody for your support
I mean I've been really happy with the videos that we've been able to put out thus far anyway
and I'm really happy that you guys have responded so well to it
like uh the, the ginger bread house building challenge is probably one of the funniest
videos that we've made in a long time
and that was in that narrow window where my voice actually came through for me
and I'm super happy that we were able to do that and I'm super happy that you guys actually enjoyed  the improv that we've been doing
like the Change game, the Whose Line game
we've actually got two more of those that we have recorded
uh that I was gonna save for a lot longer, but now that I'm sick and I'm still a little sick
I'm starting to feel better but my throat is still thrashed
unfortunately so I'm gonna give it one more day to recover
this vlog is the only thing I'm going to record today
and then we're just going to be editing today
and hopefully tomorrow we can work on some more cool stuff but
I dont know.... there's very little time left
and we are back for the holidays
so what I might do.... actually, no
This is what I'm gonna do... I have to make a judgement call here
for the next few days it's gonna be one video a day
but they are gonna be the Christmas themed videos
we do have few of those still in the pipeline
for you guys to see and hopefully
hopefully those will be coming out regularly at noon.
for the next few days and then later this week on Friday
it's not a Saturday but it's Friday
is our charity livestream where were going to be raising money for "toys for tots"
that's gonna be right here on the channel
starting at 10 AM eastern standard time
so its gonna be starting earlier than we did for the last live stream
because heh I live in LA but I'm going back home to Cincinnati
to see my friends and family which is something that I'm very much looking forward to
but in the next few days you got some special Christmas themed stuff
that is both interesting, hilarious
and ABSOLUTELY disgusting
and I can't wait to show you guys what we have in store
so thank you everybody so much for being so patient
and understanding AND for being so accommodating in the like, in the chaos of the past few days
and so many people were telling me just to rest
but I couldn't stop I had to keep going... And we had to keep recording
because I knew that we had to make this thing happen.
We are committed to doing it.. We are committed to the 12 days of Christmas
and then after that we are staying with our family and friends until the new year,
and then we all come back January 3rd or 4th, err I can't remember what day specifically,
but then next year rolls around and it's going to be an amazing year.
OH! and also... little ...little sneak peak
I know everyone... We've been hinting at bloopers.
And we've been um
mentioning bloopers, and you guys have been demanding bloopers,
for the very sketches and stuff that we've done
We actually started compiling
a mega compilation of bloopers.
It's up to 30 Minutes of bloopers
and when we were watching it back
We were just dying on the floor laughing at our own stupidity!
Of this HUGE ENORMOUS Compilation of bloopers
So we think that's going to be an excellent New Year's video
For you guys to look back on the
things that we've been making
and laugh at our horrible mistakes
So, you have that to look forward to
So mark your calendars for the charity live stream
I hope you all have a wonderful December thus far
and I hope you get to see your friends and families
This December, Christmas
Whatever you celebrate
I hope you have a wonderful holiday.
Now I'm gonna give my voice a rest.
We've got a few other things to film today.
that shouldn't be too demanding
but either way
It's going to be an AWESOME Christmas
And thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH - BYE!